hello Joe
what's going on man yeah good to see ya
thanks thanks I feel a little
overdressed sorry about looks good
you know ah look at that a little bit of
starry night there yeah you're really
into them huh oh yeah I got I got is
that yes oh you remembered yeah yes yeah
yeah it's on the phone starry night I
like about starry night it's not what
van Gogh saw that night it's what he
felt how do you know what he felt
because this is not a representation of
reality and anything that deviates from
reality is reality that has filtered
through your senses and I think art at
its highest is exactly that if this was
an exact depiction of reality it would
be a photograph and I don't need the
artist hmm okay so even photographs that
take you to a slightly other kind of
dimension as you gaze upon them it's
more than what was actually going on at
the time and that's that's art taken to
the craft of photography and that's why
you like it that's one of the reasons
why plus I think it was the very first
painting where its title is the
background think about that this could
have been called you know in the full
painting obviously this is a snippet
yeah yeah so there's a town there
there's a cypress tree there's a church
steeple it could have been called the
cypress tree it could have been called
sleepy village it could have been called
rolling hills but no it's called starry
night and everything in front of it
everything in front of it is just in the
way and how often do you paint something
where the title is the background that
that's my point and in this particular
case the background is the universe and
soap so for me this was a pivot point in
art and it's 1889 which is recent given
the history of paintings and you know
there go all the way back so yeah there
it is that your favorite painting ever I
have to say yeah yeah a vest and a fire
if it's not what are you doing for for
five ties that have this painting on
them in different ways yeah so I'm
all-in I'm all-in what's interesting is
that the town is what have you seen
starry night in bacon somebody did look
dig it up on the screen today somebody
did it in bacon it's just crazy
weird yes yeah how weird go back to the
original one please what's interesting
about the original one is that the town
is realistically depicted the trees are
recognizable as trees if you ever saw a
sky that looked like that
the end would be here yeah exactly Plus
then swirling is not wind and it's not
clouds because if it was if it was
clouds you wouldn't see the Stars right
what started it's how he felt that's all
I can tell you by the way that is a real
evening so that's sorry it's not even
it's early morning the crescent moon
when it's that orientation means this is
before sunrise and that white object
lower on the horizon that sort of glowy
that's very likely Venus and that
enables us to trace what's over what set
of weeks this painting was actually
painted so it's kind of like forensic
astronomy has anyone done an analysis of
like where he must have been yeah yeah
that's well-known yeah he was in a real
place and so that he didn't pull this
out of his ass right I mean it was he
painted what he saw folded into what he
felt yeah that's how art should be I
think yeah otherwise would what do you
need artists for make cool [ __ ] the cool
stuff is something that they felt and it
came out of them yeah and they feel
stuff they artists feel feel the natural
world in ways different from the rest of
us and that's why they're artists do
they or do they just express it with oh
sorry yes they not only yes we all can
feel it but to be able to express it
that that's a whole other talent right
just you know what I think about often
why do you why do we all know who Paul
Revere is all right we all we it's a
household name yet is there any other
war ever fought in the history of the
world
where
whole name is the name of the person who
told other people the enemy was coming
we can mention his name but we can't
list the generals that all fought in
that war why it's because a poem was
written about him and he had this
mundane job let me tell people the enemy
is coming and so the artist in this case
the poet elevated the mundane to
something that forces you to to reckon
it with your understanding of this world
what joyce joyce kilmer is most famous
poem it's about a tree dogs piss on
trees you drive by trees you don't even
know they're there yet a poem about a
tree I'll never see something as lovely
as a tree oh my gosh this so the art
forces you to pause and just reflect on
things that you took for granted things
that became ordinary in your life and
they were elevated to - - they get
beatified by the talents of artists
that's a word o beatify you never know
we a defy yeah I'm using it loosely it's
the intermediate step between being an
ordinary person and being a saint the
beatification of someone in the Catholic
Church
I want thought it's making something
more beautiful oh babe okay I don't it
could have similar roots being sad would
be yeah good it could come from that but
to be it be beatified is the first steps
on route to sainthood yeah that's if I
remember the word correctly goes oh you
gotta hold up the definition to make
supremely happy Christianity declare to
have attained blessedness of heaven and
authorized the title blessed and limited
public religious honor
she was beatified six years after her
yes so I think you can't become a saint
unless you previously been beatified I
think that's the rule but I'm looking at
the number one definition there to make
supremely happy so that's that's
interesting yeah that that yeah that
moved ahead of a definition of beatify
yeah so it's a to be out of fight where
the the verb was up there you had on the
screen Roman Catholic Church
he beatified one diego an indian
believed to have a vision of a Virgin
Mary synonyms canonized sanctify how a
consecrate so I think if you take
something ordinary and you subject it to
the interpretation of an artist it can
be beatified and elevated on a level
where it becomes a household recognition
of its importance in this world hmm
so my brother's an artist my brother's
an artist so I'm kind of a fine art but
also paints and he teaches history of
art so I I've had this sort of baptism
my whole life being exposed to him I'm
the you know the the sibling scientist
but the they have an artist in the
family I this everyone should have an
artist in family I've got an uncle and
of course the the whole steam movement
science technology engineering and math
the artist got in they say wait I'm sort
of stem the stem movement they want to
throw in the a to get art as part of
that movement science technology
engineering art and math changing from
stem to steam its esteem so you get full
steam ahead steam is a better word in
that well they both good words for what
they need but that just sounds like a
bunch of awesome stuff like it does and
yeah I'm not throwing comedy and it's
like the lbgtq a really squirrely when
you start adding more letters yeah you
can add letters but if it doesn't spell
anything then the memorization has to
kick in but steam you don't have to
memorize that it's already there for you
so it's cleverly conceived I think it
the abbreviation was its tacit
recognition that these are elements in
society that advanced civilization and
grow the economy actually so in fact
there's hardly any growth economy in the
world that isn't growing because it has
been frettin not having been touched by
science or technology everything just
think about it
so if you're around running you don't
have them on your show but if you run
around saying I don't like science
science is bad science is evil okay well
then you will die in poverty if you
elect officials who believe that as well
who the [ __ ] thinks that science is bad
in 2019 and
how do they express this they express it
through sign okay so you know I'm saying
like are they saying it online I have a
book coming out in a month called
letters from an astrophysicist okay yeah
it's it's not it's not out yet I've got
it it's not how did you get a copy but I
don't even have my copy yet okay what
I'm saying in there I there's a whole
chapter on just angry people who don't
like anything including science and one
of them it's a it's a it's a riff he
just said I hate it and it signs it and
that science does bring some of the
worst things that's ever happened to
humanity and pollution and this he goes
on and on and on and on and on and so I
reply his letters from a national
physicist and I and I reply as calmly
and as rationally as as possible when
you get attacked that way but what I'm
saying is not everyone embraces
everything that science does and some
will cherry-pick it you have the science
deniers for a global warming of science
deniers with vaccines you have science
and IRAs with GMOs you know there's
there's all manner of science denying
going on in modern society and you know
we in a free society
what are you gonna do right that people
can think what they want but if if
thinking what they want influences
policy which then affects everybody then
your science denial has consequences to
the economic health of the nation and by
the way it's not only economics it's
your the economic health it's your
physical health because medicine flows
through advances in science as well as
our security well there's people that
deny some aspects of science while
conveniently using other that's where it
gets weird right you're driving a car
that's relying on GPS you're using a
phone to complain about the global
warming hoax you know you're correct
what one of my more more sort of popular
tweets was you remember when they we had
the photo of the black hole from a
distant galaxy and it was banner
headlines maybe a year ago less than a
year ago banner headlines and first
photo ever of a black hole and it was an
astounding engineering achievement to
accomplish that it was multiple
telescopes all around the world
pooling the data to get it right and it
was one of the greatest collaborative
efforts we've ever undertaken in my
field of astrophysics okay
and everybody was loving the results so
all I tweeted was scientist report first
photo of a black hole public scientists
report humans are warming the earth
oh no you brought it up ok scientists we
produce the first ever image of a
supermassive black hole 55 million light
years away the response scientist we've
concluded that humans are catastrophic
ly warming the earth response that
conflicts with what I want to be true so
it must be false well that is the
cherry-picking of science it is the
cherry-picking assignments but the
global warming thing is very much
connected to a certain type of ideology
a certain type of person thinks to the
matter to me no nonsense person what I'm
saying yes it does matter what I'm what
I'm trying to say is that is a
demographic that has cherry-picked
science to deny human-caused global
warming there are other Democratic
demographics said of cherry-picked other
science to deny other things and it's
not all located in one political
spectrum I mean one political branch
right so you tend to find liberal folk
complaining that the conservatives who
have embraced know the gluten no global
warming platform are denying science and
they need science on their side and many
of those same people are rubbing
crystals together to be healed by the
crystal energy or they're denying
vaccines thinking that there's somehow
bad for you and so so all of this
requires sum or total rejection of
mainstream science and we're living in
that world now and I don't know I don't
think it'll stop the progress of
civilization but it can certainly slow
it down and occasionally stall it well
that is certainly a problem but how big
of a problem is it like how many people
are really in denial of science in 2019
and it's got to be for me in a free
country that's not what matters what
matters is in a free country that you
elect officials who are not
officials yes you you elect people who
are scientifically literate yeah they
don't have to be scientists I or and if
they're not scientifically literate they
should be self-aware of that and then
listen to people who are right so don't
you think what they're doing though is
they're they're doing what their
constituents would like them to do
that's why I don't beat politicians over
the head ever I don't do that we're
we're we're Republic we're democracy
whatever they believe if they think
earth is 6,000 years old and they got
elected it's because the people elected
them believe there's he earth is 6,000
years old or because they're willing to
let that one go because they believe in
Oh possibly that's a good point because
you have a portfolio of thoughts and
beliefs or because he's such a profound
Christian I mean he's so profoundly
Christian that he's plenty of Legends
who are connected to science that don't
including the Pope by the way you know
can you get more Christian than the Pope
all right he believes in science now
this new pope is pretty interesting if
you read if you read his encyclical from
a couple of years ago it's it's it's a
scientifically literate doc document
yeah and know this okay so it's not he's
still religious right so Jesus still
rose from the dead and there was still
miracles and all the rest of that in the
New Testament so he's not in denial of
that but given that he is saying oh my
gosh here's something we the religious
community and scientists can partner
behind and that if we want to save life
on Earth and so we have to be better
shepherds of what is going on on this
earth and one of them is we don't want
to flood low-lying countries in the
South Pacific
where the average sea level is 10 feet
above sea level or whatever it is you're
gonna lose these countries if you keep
melting our-our-our
the nothing ice caps because that would
include a north and there's no land in
the north so the glacier ice that's
land-based ice right because any ice
that's in the water floating that can
melt and it's not going to change the
water level so it's why you can do this
experiment it's really cool fill up your
glass put some few cubes of ice in a
glass of water fill the glass up as much
as you possibly can without spilling it
and the
ice is bobbing above that level okay
because ice is about 10% buoyant on that
about 10 percent of an ice cube will be
lifted above this is this is the this is
the iceberg equation right all right
that's the tip of the iceberg well you
see the 10% above and 90% is not visible
to you this is by the way I don't want
to get to too many off-ramps here but
that's one of the one of the things that
they did right in Titanic okay if you
look at the earliest Titanic movie that
was in black and white they see this
huge iceberg on the horizon and then it
can they can't square away from it
because it oh my gosh it doesn't have to
no no
the iceberg that cuts the bottom of your
boat is a little bit I sticking out
above the water because 90% of it is
underwater and that's where the damage
occurs and in the James Cameron Titanic
the iceberg that they hit above water
was looks like a little chunk of ice no
that couldn't hurt anything all the
damage was under work anyhow so back to
this so do this experiment and then let
the glass sit there and let the ice melt
and the water level will stay the same
because when ice melts it gets takes up
lower volume than it was when it became
ice mmm and that's why pipes break I
thought pipes break just because the
water expands yeah I just described that
in the opposite direction oh I didn't
know it gets larger that's what
expansion means what kind of with your
vocabulary here right now but I'm saying
like so your ice cube is sitting at 10%
of your ice cube is sitting 10% above
the water level and it melts and becomes
water the water takes up 90% of the
volume of the ice right so that just
melts back into the water and it doesn't
overflow even though we're sticking
above the water line when you had the
glass so now let's do the opposite okay
there's water in the pipes well can I
tell you something that might blow your
mind no how many times does your mind
you at least once a day yeah at least we
need your mind blown okay here's how it
works okay so let's put water in the
pipes okay and then the temperature
drops the pipes have a certain strength
right copper pipes you know they're
rigid and I grew up around Bray
and pipes okay so no Massachusetts so
the waters in there and now the
temperature begins to drop okay
the water wants to turn to ice but it
can't because the pipe is containing it
so it just sits there okay at 32 degrees
as water even though the temperature
outside is dropping below 32 degrees
okay and it still sits there guess the
30 degrees 29 the pipe is squeezing the
attempt of this water to become ice and
the act of squeezing it prevents the
temperature from dropping okay and you
as the temperature drops depending on
how strong the pipe is and and the
temperature gradient across it as the
outside temperature continued it gets to
now 25 degrees the pipe is still holding
on to the liquid water and it's still 32
degrees inside there and it olds on to
it and this keeps happening it keeps
having you get a point where the pipe
can no longer contain the water and the
water freezes spontaneously it just goes
right down to that temperature and the
pipe is helpless in the face of this so
the point is the stronger the pipe is
the lower the temperature has to be
outside for the freezing water to break
so theoretically if you had a pipe that
was made of a stronger material than
copper you can get even lower than you
get even lower temperatures how low can
you get I cuz that when things freeze
they have to expand so what not only
when water freezes water expand when
it's it's it's a it's a remarkable fact
about water that is shared by very few
other ingredients most things when they
cool they shrink as all men know so so
so most most materials because things
cooler the vibrating molecules slow down
and they take up less space water is the
opposite of that as it passes down
through so so I'm gonna describe to you
an extraordinary fact about water and
why we're alive today okay so watch this
let's take a lake that has fish in it
okay
temperature drops outside and the lake
slowly begins to get cooler because
there's a tank time lag between the air
temperature and the waters that's why
the first freeze the lake is still there
it's got to be cold longer alright so
what happens the water gets cold on the
surface okay and it begins to okay the
water gets cold on a surface and it
begins to shrink so that water falls
this shrink that makes a denser it falls
to the bottom fine it does that down to
about four degrees Celsius as it goes
from 43 Celsius to zero degrees Celsius
the freezing point it begins to expand
and become less dense than the water so
now as the water wants to actually
freeze it stays on top when it does
freeze you freeze the top surface of the
lake well how about the water below it
it's insulated from the dropping air
temperature and the fish don't die
imagine if ice were denser than water
what would happen you'd freeze the top
layer it would sink the bottom is frozen
freeze the next layer it sinks and fish
would be systematically forced to swim
in shallower and shallower waters until
they were all freeze dried on the top
surface of the lake and all fishes would
be dead every winter I think it's every
Lake things fish what I think you
supposed to say fishes fishes is a
double plural you could do that yeah you
know fish would be dead you know I'm all
deer would you say all deers
well because generally it's one if you
had multiple kinds of deer yeah so if
you had like yeah but it's rare that
they're all in the same place you
generally have one kind of do normally
but if the ocean has many kind of fish
in the same place oh yeah that's
interesting so you'd say fishes fishes
it's like it's a double floor it's
different kinds of plural fish yeah
double blow my mind the many fishes in
the oh yeah yeah yeah so sorry she's in
the sea yeah so multiple plurals of
different have to get we're ocean water
freezes salty salt water do you have the
word fishes up there some weird anomaly
that happened where there was two or
little oxygen in the water and somehow
the frozen fish got pushed out in a wall
of ice South Dakota so there's too
little oxygen I don't know I can't
explain that over there if you look at
the if you look at the green in the
water most likely it's algae so that
happens with certain lakes that get
polluted with certain types of a you can
kill the lake but by doing that well you
get it in the ocean to get these zones
but I don't see how you get frozen fish
though that's incredible but stop go
back up yeah scroll down so we could
read it fish frozen a wall of ice and
South Dakota's Lake Andes National
Wildlife Refuge that's incredible man is
that a video Jaime
yeah I don't know how they froze because
they can just swim to where it's not
frozen so I'd have to I'd have to do
more homework on that one to see what
what caused that Wow so my point is
because of this property of water that
ice floats it insulates the bottom
layers of the lake and fish can survive
over the winter that's work too right
insulate so you can inside you get a
yeah sure yeah yeah I mean if you put a
barrier between you and the changing
elements outside that's basically an
insulating layer ice fishing know I
never know that a university life person
wait do women go ice fishing to get away
from their husbands they do yeah why do
people golf you know the ice fishing is
particularly weird because you have to
continually scoop out the ice and maybe
even drill again right so that works
because frozen water is less dense than
non frozen water and it's one of the
rare ingredients for which that's oh and
it's likely there would be no life on
land or anywhere on earth if that were
the case if the opposite of that were
the case so water is a very special
ingredient to life on earth it's cited
by many religious folks is saying see
earth is sacred for these it's in the
list of special ingredients for what
make earth habitable for life that is a
really strange thing though that if you
can contain it somehow an incredibly
strong pipe yes it won't freeze yes it
won't freeze what is a temper
is there a number well that's why that's
why pipes don't freeze when it just hits
30 degrees outside that's not when you
hear it it freezes when it gets really
low when you crack it yeah and then
it'll break the copper like it's paper
and tear it like it's like it's nothing
now on the flip side of that try this at
home take an ice cube that's like at 30
degrees okay how would you measure that
pull out an ice cube and just because
there'll be at near zero Fahrenheit if
you if you have a good freezer just pull
out and leave it on the counter put put
it on a wooden cutting board okay
and just let it sit there for like 10
minutes and it's temperature will come
up there'll be a point where it hasn't
melted yet but you can take it and
squeeze the ice cube and you can force
it to melt by squeezing it because
you're forcing it into a smaller volume
that it currently contains and the only
way you can accomplish that is if the
ice turns to water then it will occupy a
smaller volume so the act of squeezing
ice can actually melt it so if you had
some sort of a pipe that could
physically constrict like something that
had threads it in there could wind down
to a smaller size you could stick a
cylinder of ice in it and you could
slowly crank it oh yeah yes yes it would
melt yes you can melt if you have some
machine that squeezed ice yeah and the
colder the ice is the hard this the the
more you the the harder it would be for
you to squeeze it to accomplish that so
it's sort of fun with ice in fact you
know what else you can do this is a
harder experiment to do if you take us a
a mesh like a screen mesh that's to be
sort of wider openings then a screen
door would so what would this be like a
fence like a chain-link fence and hold
horizontally and get a big block of ice
and just place it on top a block of ice
is heavy what will happen is the ice the
weight of the ice will melt the ice in
the contact points of the chain itself
because it's feeling that pressure to
squeeze it into a smaller volume but by
the time it melts the ice has now passed
through the grate and it will refreeze
on the other side
so you can actually pass a block of ice
through a chain-link fence vertically
just by pushing it yeah it's pretty it's
pretty cool it's a slow experiment but
it's wrong
I meet depends on the temperature the
ice and how and how and how much it
weighs because the pressure is what this
is why this is why you can ice skate why
can you skate on ice because the edge of
the blade is very high pressure on the
ice and it's melting a bead of order
you're actually gliding on water when
you're skating you're not skating on
slippery ice really yes I thought you
were just cutting the ice with the blade
well so the blade have you ever seen a
sharpened blade it's not just flat
there's actually a concave cross-section
to it so each edge the left edge and the
right edge is is basically at a knife
edge mm-hmm okay not quite as sharp as a
knife but it's you can feel how it's
it's sharp so that when you lean on that
edge either your inner edge or outer
edge your entire bodyweight is being
held up on this on a very narrow surface
area of the blade so the pressure is
extreme it's like you know thousand
pounds per square inch you don't weigh a
thousand pounds but you're not skating
on a square inch right so you you do the
math on that and what you can have is
you will skate and you're actually what
makes it so slippery on ice skates is
because you're moving on a bead of water
that freezes right behind you as you go
past it dude yeah so it's possible for
ice to be so cold you can't really skate
on it because even that pressure is not
enough to melt it how cool would it have
to be that I last I did a calculation
was really cold like tens of degrees
below zero
how does dry ice work oh it's just
frozen carbon dioxide that's all so
here's the difference here's the
difference you have a block of frozen
h2o and a block of frozen co2 so there
they are it turns out the air pressure
on earth is high enough at sea level is
high enough to allow the ice to melt and
sustain a liquid state okay
the co2 under air pressure normal air
pressure it wants to melt but it can't
sustain a liquid and it goes straight to
gas if we had much higher air pressure
you could you could have co2 melt and
have liquid co2 so now watch what happen
so so okay kind of blow your mind again
this is just this is really good stuff
okay it's good like physical chemistry
so here you go so watch it happens so
what happens if I reduce the air
pressure okay well the transition from
ice to water is still the same it's not
affected but the boiling point is
affected as you know cooking times have
to be adjusted on mountaintops because
when you boil water it's not 212 degrees
depending on the height of the mountain
there's less air pressing down that
that's preventing it from boiling okay
the boiling point is not some absolute
facts about the water it has to do with
what the air pressure is sitting above
it if you have extremely high air
pressure water has to go to a much
higher temperature before it boils so
our so the boiling point of water that's
reported in all textbooks is at sea
level at one atmospheric pressure that's
how you get 212 degrees if you start
reducing the atmospheric pressure it's
210 degrees 205 degrees 200 degrees 190
degrees 180 degrees 180
oh yes and so that's not as hot as 212
degrees so you got to cook the food
longer all cooking times are increased
for this reason so now watch I'm not
done with you Oh
let's keep reducing the air pressure
okay theoretical like possible on earth
no no Himalayas yeah but or take it up
you can ascend in some kind of copter or
some kind of device our air balloon or
whatever but I'm saying you can do this
experiment in in a laboratory okay okay
you keep reducing the air pressure
boiling port keeps dropping it's a hard
in 70 degrees 150 hundred twenty a
hundred degrees Fahrenheit
80 degrees Fahrenheit fifty degrees
Fahrenheit forty degrees Fahrenheit
thirty-two degrees Fahrenheit
holy shed what happens the ice melts and
becomes water the water evaporates and
becomes steam and all of that's
happening at 32 degrees there is an
atmospheric pressure for which water ice
and steam coexist and it's called the
triple point of water and all
ingredients have a triple point Wow Mars
Mars is very close to the triple point
of water so you can have you can have a
simultaneous bath in certain regions of
Mars a simultaneous bath because the air
pressure is so low is like one
one-hundredth Earth's air pressure it's
very very low so you know a place where
a pot of water ice cubes and steam are
coming out all at once it's at the
triple point so so so here's the lesson
here is we live life in our world at one
atmospheric pressure at one the room
temperature atmospheric pressure and we
define what is normal
based on that life experience based on
how our senses interact with that
environment but the actual universe is
far freakier than what we that what our
senses are exposed our five senses are
exposed to on earth what did you think
about Elon Musk's idea about nuking the
poles of Mars in order to make it warmer
yes so some of these are kind of pie in
the sky ideas right but let's let's get
to what he's trying to get at what you
want to do is you want to introduce
warmth you want to block the ozone you
want to block the ultraviolet it's so
that you can protect organic life all
right so we have an ozone layer it's
three oxygen atoms oh three and oxytocin
likes ultraviolet light so ultraviolet
light comes from the Sun and gets eaten
by ozone it gets eaten and when you do
that the ultraviolet light doesn't make
it to Earth's surface so
even though they sell where wears
sunscreen and you've sunblock 45 yes
that's for the 1% of the ultraviolet
that gets through the atmosphere if
you're above the atmosphere you are
fried
so the because ultraviolet is highly
hostile to organic molecules and what
we're made of as life
so you want to protect you want to give
life a chance so you want to not only
heat Mars you want to find a way to
block the ultraviolet light coming from
the Sun so you need some mechanism if
not ozone or it just live underground
for example okay
and so so I don't think we should think
of the idea as a literal thing but just
it's a general principle of what you
want to accomplish on Mars in doing so
you want to warm it you want to protect
what could be the future of biochemistry
and then you see it and you and then you
wait you don't know wait too long you
want to sort of speed it up if you could
and then you terraform Mars SpaceX has
I've visited him a couple of times he's
he's got a mug you can buy there then it
has Mars on it okay and then you put put
hot liquid in it and Mars turns to an
arable blue-green marble so yeah it's
very good and it doesn't tell you that
when you so I got a Mars mug you know
and you show it off and oh my gosh what
did that happen it's an earth mug but it
doesn't look like Earth there's a lot of
people that go on also we think there's
a lot of water that was once on Mars
which is a certainty and we think it's
just sitting below in a permafrost so
you wouldn't have to bring water to Mars
by the way in the really distant future
you can just redirect a comet and get
all the water you need but how far
distant is that the Comets everywhere
dude we're in a shooting gallery yeah
that's not what I asked oh do you think
it is before we could read the ref our
weight in time yes okay sorry we know
how to do it but there's no real
incentive so there's no engineering
funded engineering plan to do it but we
know how to do it on paper we know how
to do it
conceivable way oh yeah you so there so
first of all it happens with or without
us because we are in the shooting path
of countless thousands of asteroids and
comets so what you would do is you'd
find one that's headed close to us
anyway
in the seventh orbit down the line or
the hundredth orbit down the line and
then you'd slightly deflect it in such a
way that it would then collide with Mars
or even earth if you wanted the earth
needed some more fresh water yeah I
heard that there's a possible but it
ain't the problem is if something really
big that would fill lakes worth if that
collided with earth that would just be
bad for life on earth because it's a
spontaneous deposit of energy that can
change the climate and do it so you want
to do that on a planet that you're
trying to terraform isn't that the
speculation of how water got here in the
first place
so if the jury's still out on that
there's there tags in the oceans in the
water molecule that tell you that the
water must have come from more than one
source so that's what's confusing things
we want it to be a simple thing it all
came by comets or it all came from
inside the earth through volcanoes
volcanoes emit Lakes and historically
lakes and oceans worth of water just out
of there out of there calderas so so the
problem is what as we say in science
over determined there's plenty of comets
to have delivered all the water there's
plenty of water that could have come out
of out of volcanoes to give us all the
way so but in the oceans it's clearly a
mixture and so the final word is still
out on that what do you think about
what's going on why now with the
protesting of the building of this
largest and latest telescope yes the the
the TMT 30 meter telescope which would
be you know the largest ever by far of
any kind of telescope the history of
astronomy is one where bigger telescopes
become bigger buckets to collect light
that's the only telescopes today are the
same as telescopes when they were
invented they're just bigger
all right the principle behind them is
bigger because what they're doing is
simple all you're trying to do is get as
much light as possible and the more
light you get
dimmer is the object you can detect and
the farther away is the object you can
see and so for every generation of new
large telescopes that have been built it
is it has increased and deepened our
understanding of our place in the
universe so that's just the that's the
background the proposal is for a thirty
meter telescope largest ever on the Big
Island of Hawaii in Mauna Kea where
there other telescopes there well that's
where the Keck is right yeah I think if
I it's where the Keck is I think they
they sighted it in a place that sort of
tucked behind most sight lines to it but
that's not so much what's important here
it's that the Native Hawaiians from what
I've read view the mountain as a sacred
place and so to put a telescope yet
another telescope there becomes sort of
invasion of sacred land and so so yeah
it's it's it's a there's a standoff last
I looked
I mean people protesting in the streets
and there's some Native Hawaiians who
embrace this because it means jobs high
high quality jobs
engineering jobs he's got to build it
got to maintain it there's an entire
supportive infrastructure for that that
means jobs and it's done in
collaboration with the University of
Hawaii and the all the other telescopes
are partnered with the University of
Hawaii where people are educated there
and so so at the end of the day you have
to ask well how are you going to make
decisions going forward are you make
them democratically then you take a vote
or you do you want the natives to to be
the deciders of their own fate and is
that democratic okay so in the natives
vote okay or is it the few people who
are protesting do they win the day I
mean it's it's complicated and it's very
it's very there are a lot of nuanced
issues going on there there's a there's
a branch of thinking that the the United
States government and and normal
municipal leaders have no authority over
it there's some who claim that this is
native hawaiian property that does not
belong to any municipal entity of the US
government so therefore even state
representatives have no say right so
there's a lot going on there okay but if
I were to weigh in this is how I would
do so okay I would say first I think
what should happen is I don't know if
they even have the the infrastructure
system is set up but if they could set
it up this way if the mountain is viewed
as sacred by the natives
the natives should have entire say of
what happens to the mountain okay that's
how I think that should be so now what
you want to make sure is that whatever
decision gets made and voted upon by the
natives that it's fully informed you are
you don't want to vote being misinformed
or under informed in any election let
alone whether you're voting for a
telescope on your sacred mountain okay
otherwise you're voting out of nowhere
right yeah you know you're influencing
your future based on partial information
and decisions based on partial
information or bad decisions no matter
what okay
so I would say hold the vote with the
natives and make sure everybody's fully
informed and here's a bit of information
I just want to add to the information
okay you know what we do as
astrophysicists we study the universe
rather passively at that we sit there at
the end of a telescope and wait for
light to reach us it's not a petri dish
where we stir it or heat it or freeze it
or crack it or we're just kind of there
communing with the cosmos my PhD thesis
was significantly fed by data that I
obtained from mountaintops at telescopes
I got my data from mountains in Chile
settar to Lola and it employed all the
natives of the natives the local local
people that's another telescope that so
there's all these telescopes that all
have specific
access points to the universe they're
not all asking the same questions right
and so it's the collection of all the
data that gives us the complete
understanding what we think is a
complete understanding of the universe
so what we do is try to understand our
place in the universe and all I'm gonna
say is that if you have power over what
happens on that mountain and it's sacred
to you because whatever that is it is
something important to you and your
sense of your understanding of your
place in this world that would be
spiritual significance I can tell you
that what we learn as astrophysicists
from those mountaintops gives us a
deeper understanding of who and what we
are in this universe so I would say that
whatever is your concept of God be it
the creator of the universe the spirit
energy that pervades all of space and
time whatever is your concept the
discoveries of astrophysicists bring you
closer to it I get your perspective let
me be the opposing view they feel well
I'm not trying to no I know this is
information I'm putting this is
information and I walk out of the room
and then you all vote right I'm not you
know we believe in democracy here and
majority rules that's it that's kind of
a good thing it's kind of worked all
right but if it's not majority rules I
don't know how they're going to make
decision but let's say invent a future
where the natives vote if they vote I
wanted to make sure they heard what I
just said and and now take control of
your own fate I just don't think they
care I think they've decided that that's
a sacred space and they don't want
anybody doing anything to it then that's
their decision them you think that's
okay I know I don't
I don't judge Peeples but if you wanted
to make a convincing appeal to them know
what I just told you that's it that is
all I would tell them and when they vote
I want them to understand that fact I
could take it one step further and say
mountaintops because of the access they
give astrophysicists and and by-proxy
us all to the universe our sacred places
to scientist okay now it's not sacred in
a religious sense but it's sacred in a
in terms of a pathway to knowing and
understanding who and what we are in
this universe we place great value on
that so but it's not our land that's
with you know specifically these things
have Europeans didn't come to Hawaii and
find fine legions of scientists they're
conducting experiments okay they found a
t'v peoples governing themselves so so
so that's that the consequence if it
gets voted down and that's permanent and
there's no way around that
that telescope is still gonna be built
it just won't be built in Hawaii well
where will it be built there you have to
be built on mountaintops yeah so there
are the mountaintops an issue right yeah
you want to be above you know somewhat
see clouds and haze and and you want a
dry environment so there's less rain I
went to see what clouds you visited yeah
very good the Keck more than ten years
ago the first time and it was I got very
fortunate it was a night where the moon
was not out yes
moon is not the astronomers favorite
thing yeah you want the darkest sky you
can we were worried as we were driving
up there that was really cloudy but we
drove through the clouds and got to the
top and we got to the observatory and it
was the most amazing without telescopes
just we there was telescopes there but
without telescopes it was the most
amazing view of the sky I'd ever seen in
my life and it changed my perspective of
our place in the universe looked like
you were on a spaceship like we were
flying through the universe because of
the diffuse
lighting in on the big island because
it's all set up so that it doesn't ruin
what they're trying to accomplish at the
CAC reflections in the wrong place not
only that if there was a moon out and
you did ascend up through the clouds the
moonlight illuminates the clouds and you
are an island in the middle of white
cotton yeah and you're not even
connected to the earth it's what you
imagined Mount Olympus would have been
I've been there for them when that
happens with the gods up there and it's
kind of that's their place it's there so
so so yes and so any my my brethren my
fellow astrophysicist who have also
observed from mountaintops by the way
it's becoming a lost art because it's
not lost but it's becoming something we
don't do anymore something called
service observing will you put in your
observing program and it's Hana to a
technician at the telescope who points
the telescope gets the data and sends it
back to you so the next generation
doesn't have the experience that my
generation did because there was a
pilgrimage to the top of the mountain
and you converted your life's path you
we converted your life schedule to
become nocturnal
and in so doing you you know this is the
journey was long enough because you're
in the middle of nowhere now you got to
go nocturnal and by the time you're
ready for this
you are communing with the cosmos it is
you the detector the telescope and the
universe and there's an eerie silence up
there too because you don't hear any the
hum of maybe the the drop of the motor
or of the telescope but that's it and so
so all I'm saying is if they choose to
not have it the tell us we'll go
somewhere else one of them is the Canary
Islands these are also volcanic hilltops
not as high as as Mount aquella that's
at 14,000 feet by the way I should have
checked it what temperature water boils
at the top amount of K we could have
rounded that story out but I think it's
around a hundred eighty degrees actually
I think I did actually calculate it one
time but anyhow so so you'd find a
mountaintop and we'll put it somewhere
else and the data won't be as good
but that'll be a consequence of it and
none of that'll go to Hawaii how do you
think that's gonna get resolved though
if you had to guess I don't know um I uh
I just don't know a lot of people are
against it including Jason Momoa
Aquaman's against it Oh uh-huh
who's out there protesting yeah and so
when you get celebrity types to put the
weight of their name behind it it it
magnifies the cause of others even if
they're in the minority yeah and so I
like I said I think natives should has
everyone know who all the natives are is
it is there some listing so that they
can all vote for this one thing you
wouldn't want people voting who are not
native if you're voting on whether it's
so sacred you don't want to put a
telescope there you'd want people who
have a an indigenous an indigenous
concern for what goes on there and
indigenous in reference to Hawaii's
relative every message of the word
indigenous is relative yeah especially
with Hawaii because the only indigenous
people are black people in Africa
because life human life began in Africa
you everyone else traveled to where they
were so so native its you set a
timeframe to declare what is native and
what's not yeah and a native and it's in
its simplest form is are you born there
so I'm a native New Yorker I'm born
there
but I wasn't the original settler there
I would my species did not form on
Manhattan Island
so everybody traveled to where they are
they just got there before the Europeans
and so that has become the definition of
indigenous all right were you there when
the Europeans landed then you're
indigenous but to other life-forms on
that on that rock on that hawaii's are a
volcanic it's a volcanic archipelago you
know how that happens by the way you
have all these multiple volcanoes in
there sir and a string you ever wonder
why how that happens so you did wonder
what you did you know why oh because
there's a hot spot beneath Earth's crust
it's just sitting there
okay and when you're beneath Earth's
crust stuff doesn't move around the way
it does on Earth's crust Earth's crust
shifts okay so that hot spot gurgles up
makes a volcano then the hot spot goes
dormant but the cot that shelf still
drifts you still have continental drift
so it drifts then the hot spot says time
for me to gurgle again it girls up now
you get another volcano and then it goes
dormant that volcano goes dormant it
shifts you get another one any time you
see an of Islands jet guarantee they're
made by volcanoes over enough time for
continental drift to have shifted the
plates over the hot spot of Earth's
mantle so do you think what they're
concerned with is the eventual spoiling
of this beautiful natural resource that
slowly but surely people are putting up
houses there and developments and all
these different things and then the
scientists are saying we need this
sacred land because we're gonna put a
volcano and they like look this is
already this is already a I mean we're
gonna put a telescope there's already a
telescope up here enough you think
that's what it is they're trying to halt
the progress of civilization or I mean
maybe progress is a bad word the
expansion of civilization yeah I mean
let's go back what did Teddy Roosevelt -
he said we got to preserve these lands
yeah because they're beautiful and by
the way he said that after he shot all
those elephants and tigers lions and
tigers and bears yeah I mean I hail from
a museum the American Museum of Natural
History would where he's the patron
saint of that museum what happened was
he realizes how important this land is
and how beautiful it is and he is the
he's the patron saint of the National
Park System so so that's the secular
version of sacred right we don't say
it's sacred but we've all decided as a
community that we care about these lands
and you don't want to drill on it you
don't want to put housing was it Lyndon
Johnson's wife Lady Bird Johnson who
said our freeways that were so carefully
building after the Second World War the
Eisenhower freeway project okay you know
the interstate system is this is our
country we want to keep it beautiful so
certain
wretches over there are no billboards
billboards would you know would change
your relationship to nature so certain
stretches of interstate or secularly
sacred if I can say that so I remember
visiting visiting Australia and there's
the the famous rock in the out in the
outback the police help me I get I get
my correct pronunciation of this uluru
and it said it's I'm told it's one
coherent geologic rock it's not just an
assembly of rocks and so I don't know
enough about the geology of it but I do
know that the Australian Aborigines
uluru and ok iconic red rock look at
that cool thing okay so that is one sort
of geologic thing and and climbers want
to climb it but that's heat its miles in
circumference okay so we visited it I
rented a bicycle with my wife and kids
and we rode around it okay so now that
is sacred to the local indigenous
peoples so they don't want you to climb
on it well I'm a rock climber right you
know what do you care I'm not gonna ruin
it I'm not gonna they don't want you to
climb on it and I try to think to myself
is there a counterpart to this that
would sort of wake up a westerner to say
I get it
alright now suppose some people from so
natives from Alaska or from the some
tribes from Africa or some Aborigines
came up from these remote places of the
world walked up to the Vatican and said
we want to climb the walls of this
Vatican just for sport what would we say
we want to climb the walls of st. Paul's
Cathedral in downtown London
what would you say no yeah but are those
comprable maybe we want to
down the tower of Big Ben you're gonna
say no
get the [ __ ] you would say no these
are important structures to us no are
you gonna say are the equivalent all we
built those you know the natives didn't
build the rock right exactly
okay it depends on how important that
detail is to you all I'm saying is on
the level of weeks say this is sacred
you say that is sacred and now you're
gonna have different rules for who's
climbing what I think it'll for to force
you to take pause so here's an argument
in full in like supporting what you're
saying look at what's going on with the
Himalayas I mean it's the human [ __ ]
that they had they leave behind their
welcome I'm so disturbing yeah the
climbers yeah it's horrible it's really
horrible I mean they there's tons of it
tons of human waste okay so what you do
there is if it's still not a problem
that people are climbing it's that
they're leaving waste you don't stop the
climbers you tax them at some level so
then now you have cleanup crews that
come up after them good so they're your
own Taksim you make it worth it all
right understand like they leave the
bodies up there right you know that they
can't that's what I heard that's what I
heard
well why do you think they can bring
tons of [ __ ] when they can't even bring
bodies here's what I'm saying when they
invented cars and cars were killing
people in the street because people have
known how to cross the street they don't
know where to cross the street people
don't know how to stop the cars they say
well cars are actually a pretty useful
thing do we ban cars no we make
stoplights oh people across our will we
make crosswalks oh let's put lanes so
the cars don't hit each other and and
let's make airbags so that you don't fly
through the windshield alright so there
are ways around problems if you value
the thing that it is that you want to do
so if people even crap up there you make
them bring it back or you develop a
system that enables the stuff to come
back no matter what
and if you can't do that you don't want
it messed up then cancel the whole
operation we didn't cancel cars we got
really innovative about having kids
difference between cars and human [ __ ]
that's left in the side of the mountain
I think the real problem too is I think
if you value mountain climbing and you
want to keep doing it then you've solved
the problem this is what engineers do
that's all they do
right because what's your problem solve
it being able to bring those bodies back
because the physical limitations of the
human body
it's barely you barely have enough juice
to climb it's so thin the air so thin
it's so dangerous and the energy draw on
you is so long leave those bodies there
was that the human ship that you're
talking about or Zell there's no you're
talking about the fact that humans were
there that we got we were not very clean
about our presence that's what you're
talking about well we're just being
human we have to go and you got to go
you got to go when we got to go up there
you just open up the hatch and let it
rip down the side of a mountain and the
resulting you know in the space station
they recycle your urine and your then
your crap congratulations to them yeah
because that put engineers on the
problem I mean my cycle it they extract
all the water from it and then what's
left is highly dried and he joined in a
role yeah yeah water is water its water
molecule that's the thing about by the
way every graph you see this people's
pee is in it that's correct
yeah so you got about a bottle of water
here hey vampy okay this has Napoleon's
penis yes yes there are more molecules
of water in this bottle then there are
bottles of water this volume of order in
all the world's oceans so in other words
if you drank this and peed it out okay
you have enough molecules in european--
your sweat and then in the the moisture
that you exhale all that goes back into
the environment scattering into all
sources water of the world and there's
enough of those molecules to occupy
every half liter of water that that
covers the surface of this earth so that
given enough time you scoop a cup of
water out of there I don't even care if
you filter it the h2o is still there
that is water that has passed through
the kidneys of Abraham Lincoln Genghis
Khan mm-hmm Joan of Arc
hey Socrates Plato no Jesus can I get a
bottle of geez I'm trying to get my Bill
& Ted's Excellent Adventure at list
going here okay you just ruined it but
yes Jesus would be included in that so
would Socrates yes so that is the scent
by the way the same is true with breath
of air there are more molecules of air
in every breath you take
then there are breaths of air in all the
atmosphere of the earth so when you
exhale there's enough of those molecules
to scatter and the the the air currents
will do this to scatter into every
breath of air that is inhale so when you
take a breath of air you have molecules
of air that went through the lungs of
Jesus we're all connected and there's no
way around it and the water that we have
is the water that we have right we drink
it we pee it yeah because the atmosphere
comes down as rain yeah and the rain is
the an important difference is a lot
most of the water on Earth is salt water
that you can't drink there's a limited
amount that's fresh water how much of a
by the way all the glaciers are
freshwater because that's it's frozen
rain right frozen rain here's something
that no one talks about when the
glaciers melt where does the water go
where's it go just tell me you know the
answer just back in the ocean okay so
but this is now non salty water going
into the ocean so you're mixing fresh
water with brackish water and they
occupy different places in the vertical
profile of the ocean and because salt
water is heavier than fresh water so the
freshwater occupies the top right that's
not as salty as the water at the blow
and there are circulations in the ocean
not only up and down you know northern
latitude southern latitude like the Gulf
Stream
there's also circulation top to bottom
and the combinations of all these
circulations create the stability of the
ocean if you disrupt that oh my gosh
there are animals fishes that can't live
anymore where they
to be because the salt level is
different and so some animals might go
extinct some weather patterns will
change because the ocean affects climate
so these are this is why climate
modeling is so critical yet so
complicated is because a lot of
variables that show up why can't we take
the salt out of the water you can it
just takes energy you can do but why
isn't that been being Donna
you can't you have to ask you who's
paying for the energy where you getting
the energy from it's an energy thing but
I would think that would be very
valuable I mean think about how many
people it's not valuable enough yet
that's the point
well is it that it's it's just money
dude it's just money you can ask what
does it cost to ship a bah half pint of
water from Fiji ok whatever hell is the
square bottle that you buy in a Fiji
water is it Fiji right yeah Fiji water
what does it cost to to bottle that in
Fiji ship it here relative to
desalinating the ocean it's cheaper to
ship to Fiji there'll be a day when
that's not the case and future Wars are
gonna be fought over who has access to
fresh water and the value of water will
go up and by the way the value of water
in space is ten thousand dollars a pound
so if you if you last sue a comet and
you say this is a lot of fresh water
yeah you could I guess you can bring it
back down to earth but that's expensive
you're better off selling it to NASA for
nine thousand dollars a pound because it
costs them ten thousand dollars a pound
to put water into orbit so you better
off keeping it up there
and somehow or another yeah and so if
you--if you harness water in space
you're better off trading in space with
it then bringing it back down to a
planetary surface at the moment the
economics favor that what is the
desalination process so it's it's simply
you just evaporate the water it's
basically a still it's it's it's it's a
it's a distillery right so here's here's
a pocket of water with this highly salty
and you just heat it the h2o evaporates
leaving sodium chloride behind and at
the end you get this salt deposit
at the bottom of your dish at the bottom
of your vessel oh wait a minute what
happens to lakes that used to be there
that salty lakes that used to be there
that aren't there's a salt deposit
that's the source of our modern-day salt
this is why tweeted the other day an all
table salt is is all table salt is sea
salt it just came from long buried
prehistoric evaporated seas so salt
mines and and I was I was told by some
geologists III had had a narrow and
narrow usage of the word mine I think if
a mine I think of a hole in the ground
but mining operations includes surface
operations as well so there's surface
Lakes that that have evaporated and you
get salt from that as well as the mines
that you would dig down deep below so
that hole all of that is a mining
operation my tweet only referenced the
Buried ones but it's all but it's all
from evaporated waters it's all from
evaporated it's all sea salt is the
point now nuclear power plants rely on
steam right isn't that part just just to
finish the point
so you evaporate the water and the salt
left maybe you might want to use that
make some sea salt out of it table salt
and that evaporated water condenses out
over here and that is distilled water
now you might want to mineralize it so
it tastes good because distilled water
doesn't taste good plus it's not really
healthy to drink it as you probably know
you drink distilled water it goes into
equilibrium with your minerals sucking
minerals out of you so it has the same
minerality that your body does and then
you pee it out and you'll systematically
drain yourself of important electrolytes
yeah so generally the water that you
would say tastes good and you enjoy has
some mineral bits some some some kind of
mineral minerals in it now nuclear power
plants don't they the process is using
that nuclear energy to create steam to
operate turbines and yeah basically all
of our electricity that comes from
essentially the mostly electricity is
coming from turbines that convert steam
to electricity so it's oh sorry
so you heat water the water makes steam
the steam turns the turbine and the
earning turbine generates the
electricity so so you it's it's a matter
of where do you get the energy to boil
the water that's what it comes down is
it call is it oil is it is it nukes is
it wind is a hydro all of this if you
get a hydro plant oh by the way then a
hydro plant they don't have to make
steam because they have the water the
water pressure at the base of the dam
moves through the turbines that turns
the turbines and they make electricity
so you don't have to heat anything
because they have the water pressure to
do that anyway that is also solar power
by the way because the Sun evaporated
ocean water the water lifts up becomes a
cloud the cloud moves over ground over
the land the cloud rains into the lake
that is above the dam so the energy that
got the water up there in the first
place
is all solar so you should think of
hydroelectric as solar as well as wind
energy because wind is the uneven an
equal heating of air on Earth's surface
and that creates air currents that's
also solar power there's also this also
work isn't it conceivable that you could
come up with a combination of
desalination and power plant where
you're using the heat to combine you
know to make the turbines move and then
you steam it off and that's where you
get the water from that would be a good
that's an interesting idea and I don't
know how much that's been thought about
what you're saying is I'm making steam
anyway yeah so why don't I do it suck
with salt water out yeah yeah and make
that's a nice two for one kind of thing
three for one you get salt and salt out
the other side yes salt gets all you
fresh water get fresh water and you
generate electricity yeah
so do patent it no it's free for anybody
wants it no take that run with it I have
high hopes for tidal energy because
there's certain places on earth where
tides are very powerful and they're very
and you just put some paddles in there
and you sort of and it and it works both
ways when the water comes in and out no
this is battery technology that's the
reason why la isn't completely dependent
upon solar because it seems like this is
the spot to do it like it never rains I
mean if it rains here 50 days yeah it's
crazy or any desert right and we're
you would next door to the Mojave Desert
right so so one of the problems is by
the way the deserts are generally
localized to certain latitudes on earth
it's because of general circulation on
earth so the air pockets on earth
there's a lot going on earth air moves
in a lot of ways but there's a there's
an overriding circulation of air that
has air sort of rising up at the equator
imagine a cylindrical movement of air
that that that Gerdes the earth okay
so just above the equator you have a
cylinder rotating where you have air
rising and just below the equator you
have a cylinder rotating the opposite
wave so that air is still rising at the
equator okay
so it rises at the equator its unstable
it makes clouds the equators one is the
cloudiest place on earth practically one
of the cloudiest places well how about
the other side of those cylinders where
the air descends okay okay when you have
descending air you don't make clouds
well how big is the cylinder it's about
thirty degrees of latitude wide so your
rainiest places on earth are at the
equator that's where you get the Amazon
rainforest in the lake and your driest
places on earth or at 30 degrees north
and 30 degrees south because these
cylindrical movements of air have
descending air there so the Mojave
Desert the Sahara Desert the Gobi Desert
they're all around 30 degrees north
latitude so this so we live on the
surface of the earth where there are
forces operating that are so much bigger
than us that we would not even think
about it why is an India would be a
desert because it's right in that zone
we're it not for the seasonal monsoons
it doesn't rain much in India except
when it's monsoon season so the monsoon
is sort of the exception
what would otherwise happen there and
that's why everyone loves the monsoon
and they hate it but they love it it
cools the whether they get sources water
there it is
so they ask you the question again okay
not answered sorry oh so so so battery
technology like what why isn't LA
completely solar it should be it's not
that some of it is cost
la is so car heavy all right and plus
you know there's a Lamborghini passing
me at 20 miles an hour on the 405 that
this is the the land of wasted
horsepower right so any place that has a
lot of sunlight should be thriving on
solar panels and you guys aren't I
looked around very few how very few
homes have solar panels and I don't
fully understand that you could if you
did that then you'd run your own run off
your own power you can do this yeah you
can do the equation difficult by the way
and so so yeah I mean the price might
have to come down a little further you
don't really see the full price of oil
it's it's subsidized in ways that are
not obvious to us you know we built the
roads with our taxes so that car
companies could sell you a car that you
drove on the road that they that was
built for them if they have to build all
their own roads the price of gas to go
in the car would have been much higher
the price of your car would have been
that all that would have been much
higher if the car companies do it what
I'm saying is I make a product and I
want you to use it but there's no roads
oh I convinced you to build the road so
you can buy my car and drive on that
road that's a weird way of looking at it
but in some ways it's it's full cost
accounting it's full cost accounting
what is the cost of coal it's how many
people died of lung disease of new mono
ultra-microscopic silica volcano County
OSIS okay that's the longest word in the
in the Random House dictionary yeah
that's basically black yes basically
black line you can break it up the new
mono ultra-microscopic silikov Oh with
the silicates in can Akane OSIS so
there's all medical bits except stapled
together to make that word so so what is
the cost to their health their death
the air quality asthma the total cost of
oil is not what you pay at the gas tank
it's other things that we shell out that
are not realized in the actual cost of
that source of energy
if you full cost accounted what all this
really costs then the solar option would
look way better than it does relative to
it that's all I'm telling but when
you're talking about cars and car
manufacturers having to pay for roads
isn't that they didn't say once isn't
that like restaurants having to pay for
toilet paper no restaurants going
restaurants have to pay for land
that you would park your car on to go
into the restaurant not in New York City
but in places where everybody has cars
you don't have valet parking I my
restaurant will not occupy the entire
plot of land I just bought it's gonna be
something's gonna be 1/4 of that land
and all the rests are gonna be parking
spots
I have absorbed the cost of your parking
your car in me in my acquisition of that
of that real estate for example to make
it convenient so people could use your
facility correct so right but I bore
that cost as as restaurateur right or
maybe I'm renting of course but that's
that's it does not relate to someone the
car manufacturer is being forced to pay
for the roads or that they should be
that would have been interesting had
they because then it would have changed
the pricing of everything but why would
they be are you gonna make a car no one
has a road to drive it on it's what it's
your responsibility then you don't have
a business but don't you want a car yes
so we all agree cars are good they move
fast they get you where you want to go
right so how do we as society make it
easier for people to get where they want
to go well we all chip in and we make
roads it's not entirely - before there
were cars a car nobody is sneaking you
know I want to go to Chicago tomorrow
and I'll be back on Thursday no one is
even having that thought before they
were email no one's thinking and right
these are not thoughts so I'm just
talking about all the forces that had to
align to make it actually work okay so
now what's holding back electric cars
well I might not be able to charge it it
takes a little too long to charge
compared to
my other vehicle are there enough
chargers along the way well these were
questions that were asked when people
got cars five cars and it takes guess is
there a gas station Oh
Standard Oil says we'll put a gas
station there because you're buying cars
and so it's a whole family of businesses
coming together and you're paying for a
big part of that it's not just the car
you paid for the roads that's all I'm
saying
I'm not complaining about it I'm just
describing it as a reality
I get it I just didn't understand the
the comparison to car manufacturers
paying for the days if I make a car and
I want you to buy my car I need a road
so I'm gonna build the road oh wait a
minute I convinced you to build a road
that's even better
oh my gosh I made it a national priority
oh it's a security problem we need a we
need a military design interstate system
that's what the interstates its military
that's why it goes through mountains
instead of over them that's why there
long stretches of straightaway so you
can land an airplane on it that's why
they're built above the road that's
where the surface roads are not the same
thing as highways because the highways
are not on the surface why cuz they
built up why because tanks can drive on
him without decomposing the road what
specs did we put this to to the Autobahn
the Germans invented the modern highway
system they invented the cloverleaf they
invented the off ramps they invented all
of that and their armies could move on
their roads like it was nobody's
business and Eisenhower said hey we
might get me some of that he comes back
that's probably not how he said it I'm
guessing but he comes out convinces us
all that we need to build an internist I
got nothing against the interstate
system I'm just giving you the
foundational facts for it and by the way
the interstate system costs as much as
going to the moon about a hundred
billion dollars in total cost seems like
a bargain compared to how many people
use it versus the moon and it grows the
economy that has a lot of a lot of but
basically it was sold as a security need
because if you're at war you need to
move material and personnel and you
might have to land an airplane
in an emergency way and so all freeways
do this you're gonna crash the plane do
it on a freeway happens yeah but do it
because you might land safely and if you
don't land safely the road comes to you
to get to the hospital don't crash in a
forest we can't get to you right I can't
get emergency vehicles good call yeah
you know have you seen this new Porsche
has a new electric vehicle there's about
to release and I haven't seen a solution
airy groundbreaking technologies charge
much faster you could charge up to 80%
in 20 minutes because it's double the
well pull up the information was it
wattage or amperage well what just just
a couple of things that's different
battery you can't cheat physics so so
yes some batteries charge faster than
others but what's what really drives the
charging speed of battery is the is the
voltage over which you charge the
battery and it goes as the square of the
voltage so super charge so if you charge
a an electric car in your 120 volt home
electricity it could take 30 hours if
you go to 240 volts okay
it'll take you know 10 hours if you go
to 384 volts so you keep going up that
drops precipitously and you can get a
voltage where the thing will charge in a
few a couple hours yeah we have a
supercharger here oh he's only yeah yes
I'm set up here for my Tesla so there
you go which specially asked quickly yes
yes yeah cool yeah so your charge in it
in at most 90 minutes I don't think they
call it that anymore I think they own
them the superchargers no there's the
the Tesla I think they call it a they
have like an S raven they have
difficulty s anymore no it's not the P
100 D that's the that's the heart they
don't battery capacity okay now they I
think they have it based on whether it's
a single engine or a double engine
they've simplified things the guys have
removed all the labels to make it a
little slicker sewed in the Porsche is
it just they're selling a higher voltage
charger to you or is that is the battery
so completely different Google
ten interesting things about the new
Porsche Tyco can how do you say it I can
that's the articles reading today mhm
that's cool so my concern is batteries
are still kind of 19th century
technology yeah you know invented the
battery Volta Alexandre Volta Wow that
makes it's cool yeah voltage vowel is
volts come from him
well yeah yeah all these guys got you
know they got famous so Tesla we got a
car named after him the guy had a nose a
car there's actually a unit of
electromagnetism named after Nikola
Tesla
yeah it's Webber's per square meter I
think so it's a it's like the the
density of magnetic field strength
within a certain area through through a
surface so Betty she charged by an
inductive plate the eventual trusted
Porsche claims that the Porsche Turbo
charging system charges at 300 15,000
watch kilowatts
15 minutes 80% in just 15 minutes
oh that's cool it's not clear how they
will prevent battery overheating maybe
they want good luck so it could be
vaporware but we'll see but what but
it's game on that's what that means
yeah it's game on whether it works or
not it's like people Tesla is on notice
everybody's on notice yeah oh my gosh
I'm gonna lose market share because
people want to buy an electric car and
so you didn't want something that's
gonna charge fast and that's the number
one complaint that most people have over
electric cars where you find a way to
okay so that's one way but another way
is you find a way to swap batteries as
quickly as it in less time that it takes
to fill a tank yeah you know how much
time do you stand there with your hand
on the nozzle waiting for the gas to go
in alright so they would have to have a
mountain of battery sitting there
waiting for people to just come in is
that any worse than a mountain that then
at dinner then a sunken reservoir tank
of gas there's no different why is that
any different probably larger volume
right possibly but so what if it's
economic you just do it right and if the
battery is all at the bottom of the car
and it's going NASCAR you run in pop it
up
take out the battery / that's when
you're off do you think that's the
future why not
that's better than charging the battery
you don't have a car do you
no I do as a yeah I do have cars now I
didn't used to I didn't used to
expensive his help to garage it in New
York they just went up the price just
went up the big the big a price point of
that was when did the average cost to
garage a car for a month in New York in
Manhattan equal the average cost of a
two-bedroom home in the United States
and we've passed that cost of rent yes
yeah of course Lord sir it was like some
600 a month or something - ran a parking
spot you rent a parking spot right one
spot one spot I'm a sonnet number month
and you can rent the home in many places
in the suburbs somewhere for 600 so I
now have a Tesla yeah so I own it up
they're expensive by the way sorry yes I
have the X so that's my utility vehicle
the X is the SUV a very high
acceleration as you know and but yeah
there's there's no maintenance on it
right there's no oil change there's no
you know the only moving part is the
what you turn in the wheels with right
there no Pistons nothing so you know
cars really should have been this 100
years ago and then we would have had a
hundred years of clever engineering to
perfect that you ever see the
documentary who killed the electric car
you know I haven't but I know about it
and I know some of the background story
behind it and the electric car was one
of the first concern because electricity
was all the rage a hundred years ago
let's electrify the cities this days
Edison there's tests everybody wants to
do everything electric and the car had
just come out let's do it electric so
this was not a new concept and it's
unfortunate that more sort of innovative
thinkers hadn't been brought to task on
how to perfect the electric car
speaking of Tesla electricity what did
you think about Tesla's initial idea
that Westinghouse shot down to sort of
broadcast electricity so that people
could just pull it out of the air yes so
the the people in the nikola tesla fan
club somehow feel that he got wronged in
his life okay
and surely some of that is true with
regard to his business acumen and
patents and and who owns the patent and
who does does he have good business
sense is he as savvy or as as sneaky
whatever other words you might apply to
Edison all right so I get that but his
contributions to electromagnetism are
real and recognized in the world of
physics like I said there's a unit of
electromagnetism named after him so
don't come crying to me say he was not
recognized by my people
okay he's recognized he had some ideas
that were a little out there and out
there on a level where it almost
certainly would have not worked and
here's why okay electromagnetic energy
is communicating between us I see you
that's because visible light is
reflecting off of your scalp okay to me
it's reflecting off of my nose back to
you you can ask how much energy is in
that well not much it's not much energy
in a visible light photons if you stayed
there long enough you might feel a
little warmth from it but no you're not
gonna drive a car with that energy
you're not gonna run a motor with it
okay
well of what good is it oh you know what
we found we can use electromagnetic
radio waves which are the lowest form of
electromagnetic energy lowest energy
level of all of your life we can
straight away it's not to transmit
energy that's not the point of it the
point is to transmit information and
information became what characterized
the modern era and that's why in the
1950s and 60s when everyone is imagining
flying cars and motorized sidewalks
everything is running on energy because
they're thinking energy is going to be
free in the future but what they didn't
figure was that information would be
free or easy to transmit and to generate
and to store and to to delete and
whereas the the energy that would take
to move things and to drive things that
would be a problem no one saw that
coming nobody saw that coming so as your
photons get higher and higher energy
yes you can start doing things with them
you get x-rays and gamma-rays
but that's not what Tesla was referring
to he was talk about moving radio waves
through the space that would charge
things up you can't pack sufficient
energy in your radio wave to do anything
we need to do
mechanically currently current well back
then would it be sufficient it might
have been something you could have done
with your radio waves cuz the needs were
no but no snow I take that back that was
the height of the industrial revolution
that was the age of the Machine the age
of the giant turbines radio energy is
not touching that well but wasn't it
possible that he was considering it for
things like radios or light bulbs or
household items would it be possible to
use that power for that so now what so
what happens so the radio waves if you
had enough power in radio waves to
generate a light bulb to power a light
bulb well through the air are you
standing in the way of this this energy
has pathways we now send energy through
wires because you're not standing in the
way of the wire the wire is buried the
wire has insulation suspension you want
to move it through the air and you want
to walk around like no that's not how
that works but what I've heard if you're
moving inner energy through the air to
power something that itself could kill
you the energy powering through that
moving through the air could kill you
unless you you bring a little bit amount
and then you store it and then use it
later you could do it that way sure so
we're sort of batteries yes you need a
storage system but you would still
probably have some sort of residual
effect of having this stuff broadcast
through the air and who knows what I
would do to human health if you needed
that much energy right now the energy to
transmit information is so low that it
no it has no effect on your health
that's why I can pull out my cell phone
I'm in a brick whether this is fake
brick that's fake brick I made up bills
real brick that no it's nice it is go
touch it
I don't believe you good was it rough
bricks go touch the bricks man Jesus
Christ he thinks we got fake bricks who
do you think we are
okay you guys thought I was a liar cut
weird now let me be on there so it's a
veneer a brick veneer okay the whole
thing real building so it's not
structural bread slice the end of bricks
and then they mortar and everything okay
so so we're both right we'll bring it
but it's not structural this real fabric
so here I am a real fake so we're inside
I can pull out my cell phone and have a
phone call yes these are microwaves of a
frequency that can penetrate walls send
information to my cell phone and I can
communicate using information and not
have that energy kill me but it's not
enough to power the actual it is not
enough to power the device correct so
until us everyone is thinking he's got
the solution to the future transmission
of energy no he doesn't well I don't
think anyone saying that but what he did
and his fans do but back then there were
no computers back there were no
television but we did have machines it
was the era of the big machine right but
I don't think he was insinuating that
you could use I don't know what he
wanted to power with it I don't know
what he would have powered with it if
not light bulbs and other things you
know one thing you brought up that's
really interesting you talked about
light reflecting off of things are you
aware that BMW painted a they painted
one of their cars vantablack I saw this
is the jet black yeah yes I saw my soul
and recently black yes so light can
bounce off of it so not only can't drive
it because people won't be able to see
it at night Oh
literally saying like this is just the
theoretical you want to you can line it
with with the triage of it cuz I'm sure
I saw one in a parking lot it's [ __ ]
it's very bad I saw one in real life
it's that's not what I saw I saw a
sports car purchase vantablack car they
have I saw a sports car that was it was
not this the car you have up there I
don't know what that is what I saw a BMW
that they painted vantablack okay well
then that mess is black is available I'm
on their badass low to the ground sports
car and so what no it's not available
commercially what do you want me saying
so I'm saying that for BMW it's not it's
not something they're off I'm in LA you
have all your cars here anything that is
everything showcased here what I didn't
see it in New York I saw it here in LA
well I'm sure
or so maybe wasn't BMW maybe somebody
else did and I'm just saying BMW if
someone did it BMW didn't make it
themselves okay someone must have done I
mean you can do it it's a real thing
vantablack okay so one of the principles
of stealth is that if you send a signal
to it it never comes back to you so you
have no sort of radar measures its
existence correct but there are two ways
you can do that one of them is you
cannot reflect back okay but so by
absorbing it right okay so jet matte
black will absorb it and not reflect it
back but if there's enough energy coming
at it it will heat up because you can't
get something for nothing here it'll
heat up the skin of that and it could be
bad for the occupants that's what they
said about the art the art will no Manta
but if you put that in the desert forget
it well they were saying even in Los
Angeles where are so hot exactly so
another way to do it is this signal
comes to me and I reflect it in a
direction that is not back to you so the
b-2 bomber is not only non reflective
back to you it takes the signal and
reflects it and double bounces it so
that all of your energy gets sent in
other directions and not back to you so
it doesn't then keep the energy that was
sent to it
so that's another way to do it another
there's another stealth which was
featured in one of the recent not recent
four years ago James Bond movies where
light that comes at it the light that's
behind it goes around it coherently and
continues to come towards you so that
you think you're seeing what's behind it
and it's not there you are seeing what's
behind it but the path of that light
went around the vessel and continue it
on its way to you so you think you're
just seeing the grass in the tree but
there's a car sitting right there you
don't know about this technology no yeah
right now it exists only for very look
up stealth light ray stealth
so the material has to be able to know
what is behind it you saying small
objects only so no no only with it that
only works in one sight line whereas if
you needed functional stealth everybody
looking at it should every path every
sight line to it should be able to see
what's behind it on the other side of
that so the way it reflects things
yeah yeah it's it carries the light beam
around it and sends it out the other
side you able to find yeah yeah what you
have is this look like a solid block and
a person is looking at it and you see
their eye out the other side it's really
freaky it's a future of stealth what are
your thoughts on digital privacy what
what do you mean well like phones yeah
like phones like did you ever talk to
someone about something and then you see
it in your Google feed do you see ads oh
yeah so we don't I mean I haven't
researched this but my wife tells me we
were once gifted one of these you know
what do you call those things did you
talk to oh yeah whatever the Google one
is is that Alexa no alexis is Amazon
right so it's Google at home and she
said don't turn that on I said why not
because it'll be listening and I didn't
believe her at first and then I started
hearing stories and so so I don't have
one but it's not because I know that
it's listening or not well substantiated
there's mean actual we've said they've
apologized for actual human contractors
listening in to conversations that
people have had having sex mm-hmm having
arguments like it's real yeah I that
seems like it should be a problem so
what's your question to me what am i all
for it or my Oh what what's your
question no but the question is one of
the things that you're getting out of
their ability to scan things is they're
tailoring things to your liking like you
know a phone tells you it's 22 minutes
until you get home I get it you're like
[ __ ] how do you know where I live
exactly I didn't tell you where I live I
got here it is and I'm just
old-fashioned about this okay I'm get
off my lawn about this
yeah I'm the old man in the rocking
chair on the porch saying go Sonny get
off my lawn but you're also scientist
okay but I don't want to okay I wear
multiple hats I'm also a dad I'm also a
husband I got all these hats for all
those things in this particular case I'm
old man and my old man sensibility is if
you track what I shop at a store
what would I buy at a store and then
send me coupons based on what you think
I'm gonna buy next based on what I've
bought before which is kind of the same
thing you're describing you have denied
me the chance of stumbling upon
something that I never thought of buying
and that takes away my freedoms and I
don't want that however they denied you
the chance of stumbling upon something
different it's not diabolical it's just
in the casual flow of life I'll give an
example
I walk into a wine shop hey can I help
you
and I say if you help me find what I'm
looking for
it's a guarantee that I will never find
what I'm not looking for and I'll end up
spending less money in your wine shop
that's a weird way look it's the art of
browsing dude you're old enough to
remember when I got to look up this word
in a dictionary and you get through six
other words whoa I never knew that weird
let me read that you learn other words
on route to the word you're targeting I
understand okay
listen that is how I feel and that's how
I think about my interaction with this
world I'd like the randomness the
randomness of it enriches my life and if
you're gonna advertise to me because you
think you know who I am maybe you do but
I'll ultimately end up spending less
money because it's the diversity of how
I think and what I buy and what I think
of buying and how I buy it and how much
money I spend that is the richness of
the life I lead your truck you're trying
to channel me into some product so some
something that fulfills a what I call it
when they have the
the study whether you're gonna buy
something or not there no no the the
table of people do you like this product
or not focus group yeah yeah am I just a
focus group to you if I am you don't
know me and I want to experience this
world
by stepping where I've never stepped
before and buying something I've never
thought of buying and if you know my
previous habits you're assuming I'm
gonna stay that way for the rest of my
life and maybe most people do and maybe
I might do that but if I do is because I
chose to not because you have decided
that that's how I should be well don't
you think the stream is jump sorry sorry
don't you think they're just doing that
because they think it would be effective
to advertise in that way so if you go
googling new Nikes and then as you're
looking at something in the Google ad
pops up and it's for new Nikes they said
hey Neal I know you were looking at the
resource we saw maybe just need a little
nudge I mean it's not I don't think
that's that diabolical I I'm the old man
on the porch I'm saying the next
generation might feel completely
different they might say I love it they
know exactly what I want you heard about
the case where they were that I read
this I haven't Rivera fide it but it's
completely plausible there was a teenage
girl who was googling pregnancy tests
cuz maybe she got pregnant okay and the
fact that she had searched pregnancy
test
she got coupons in the mail for baby
products and a parent said what is the
blood what is this
she got outed that's a little weird yeah
but it's the kind of thing that can
happen that seems that seems intrusive
certainly because pregnancy it's
enjoyable in every way no don't tell me
it's not intrusive because you want to
be seen you physical things there's not
just something that appears on your
google feed that you can cook a glance
over what's the difference we can send
you mail to your mailbox
and filling your advertising space in
front of your face with product what's
the one other people can see it I've
walked by your computer I can see it
don't look I guess I'm arguing in
principle rather than in detail okay
well let me take the counterpoint in the
on the positive side what they're doing
in terms of particularly Google in terms
of your driving right and in terms of
using of Google Maps and documenting the
history of all these people driving and
especially with things like Waze which
they acquired as they've developed a
much more efficient product than Apple
which what Apple does the Apple maps
they shred everything you do yes they do
they do they all where you've been and
where you're going that's correct but
Apple Maps sucks so you have to because
they don't have enough data they don't
have nearly the amount of data Google
has Billy what is Google giving you that
Apple Maps isn't they're telling you
you're 22 minutes from home you're time
for you to drive home what's valuing
that well yes and also okay map wait
hold on their programs far better I can
ask it how long it'll take me to go
somewhere rather than it knowing what my
drop what my day time schedule looks
like and then coming in like you said
how do you know [ __ ] you know I had
that same reaction as you did and I said
I wonder why what's causing this it's a
little creepy and again I'm the old man
syndrome some a 10 year old kid that's
only ever known this and becomes 15 and
20 that is life to them right why would
they even maybe they're not going to
complain about it but I'm the old man on
the porch but yet I'm saying it off my
loss sort of intrusiveness or at the
very least this connection that you have
to these devices and that they have to
your patterns and your information it
seems inevitable that doesn't mean I
have to welcome it with open arms but I
agree it's inevitable I agree
plus we have security cameras everywhere
everybody knows where you are if the KGB
had access to people the way we'd in
that during the Cold War the way modern
the United States has access to us
we would say oh my gosh you have taken
away your country's freedoms where the
free leaders of the free world and you
guys have imprisoned your entire
population oh my gosh the KGB would give
their right arm to have the monitoring
devices that are actively in praat place
here in the United States today
mmm we know where you are we know how
long you stayed there we have records of
it we know what street you were walking
on
we don't necessarily monitor it but we
can dig it up if we have to and with
facial recognition I can track you
wherever you are you use the facial
recognition
I use it now it doesn't care if I'm
wearing if I'm wearing a hat or
sunglasses it still knows who the hell I
am yeah
it relies on so many points yeah so many
points of cheekbones and nose I separate
and everything I think ratios of numbers
are highly powerful probes of the
structure in the form of things just so
you know the Fibonacci sequence right
that could be in there if you have a
Fibonacci head I think it's a little
overplayed Fibonacci's a little
overplayed especially once you get a
nose job you can find it in nature and
say oh isn't this beautiful but you've
overlooked all the places where it
doesn't show up in nature so many times
it it doesn't appear in more places than
it does appear right but in a lot of
living things you're living since before
he cones yeah pineapples there's a lot
of sunflower seeds it's very or
sunflower flowers yeah yeah really weird
isn't it yeah I mean it's just this
random not random but this well if the
next thing you do depends on the
previous two things you did you get the
Fibonacci series I mean that's often the
case with say you know think of things
in your life you do where the third
thing you do depends on you having done
the previous two things in this exactly
the same way that's not everything in
your life but you can surely find some
things that do that mmm I think it was
Camden New Jersey where they had such a
crime that's such that was so random no
it's not yeah Camden New Jersey had such
a crisis of funding that I think there
was a brief period of time at least I
don't know if it's changed where they
literally didn't have
for us and one of their solutions was to
put surveillance cameras everywhere and
the idea was to sort of try to capture
all the [ __ ] that was going down here it
is this is surveillance city of Camden
New Jersey okay here's a guy crime and
the intrusive tools they're using in
hopes of stopping it right yeah this was
I mean I don't remember this is after
this happening it's let me take away
your freedoms for your own safety hmm
yeah this is this is a well known you
know Benjamin Franklin wrote about it
was his famous Benjamin Franklin quote
about security and freedom yeah who
abandons freedom security is getting
neither or something yeah yeah so so
this is not it yeah they that can give
up Essential Liberty to obtain a little
temporary safety deserve neither liberty
nor safety those who sacrifice Liberty
for safety for security deserve neither
he who would trade Liberty for some
temporary security deserves neither
Liberty that he's got all combination
all permutations on that one this is so
I mean I don't wanna leave any room for
misquoting he understood that so your
your security you give up some security
for privacy I think yes and I don't know
it's a well-known place where that
should be drawn and you can actually get
an entire generation born into a state
where they think that's normal we all
now think it's normal you have to show
ID to walk into an office building oh my
gosh what would that look like during
the Cold War you have to show you in the
United States you have to show your
papers just to walk into a building well
they're also changing oh my gosh system
where if you don't want to travel with a
passport you're gonna have to have a new
40 been through then a federal driver's
license federally endorsed driver's
license I just went through that last
week yeah right so when did you go into
play when is that going ah um it's for
everybody like next year or something
it's very soon if you want to travel in
a particular way if you don't drive and
then it doesn't matter fly right we want
to fly correct correct
and I carry my passport wherever I go so
it's not really a problem for me but
so carry your passport everywhere you go
if you want to just jet out of the
country how is your brain wired would
escape no if I had four passports then
you'd say do I want to leave the country
yeah whoever that anybody in a you know
espionage movie there's somebody who has
five passports in a safes and with with
wads of cash of every currency so so I
think I worry that we're sliding towards
a state of total monitoring on the
premise that we're all better off for it
right and it's like the frog in the
heated water we don't feel it day by day
but it's happening we all agree that we
can be hand patted down just to get on
an airplane we've all accepted that
because of a handful of people a handful
look at historically handful
historically handful not even a handful
in this moment just historically and
fill the people we all say yes take my
luggage x-ray my luggage
take away my liquids Pat me down and I'm
okay with that
well that's a transition and I'm okay
with security cameras in the street it
was okay in banks we understood that but
now when I exit the bank and I'm in the
street when I'm walking and walking in
the park so I don't know I don't know
the future of that I really don't know I
saw the movie 1984 recently not a very
good movie the book is better than the
movie and I hate to be the one of the
people who say that but I was reminded
how you can create an entire state where
everyone is kept in line because
somebody is telling you we are fighting
this battle out on the front lines I'd
forgotten this from the book they're
fighting a war on the front lines you
never see the war you never hear about
the war you know anything about the war
other than it exists and you have to do
things a certain way in country so that
your country can protect itself from
these evil people that want to take over
and destroy your way of life
so everybody's under control from Big
Brother well what they didn't anticipate
though was these social media companies
would be the guards or the gatekeepers
of your privacy because that's what's
interesting is it could you voluntarily
give them all your information that's
not government's rights it's Twitter and
Facebook Google and you know all the
stuff that we use on a daily basis that
is access to everything that you do it's
almost inconceivable to someone outside
of this generation that there would be a
company that would provide a service and
through that service you would give up
all notions of privacy all privacy yeah
because literally you have a microphone
that's listening
everywhere you go you have a bug right
there you can around with you I mean I
don't remember yeah you've been you've
been pin bucked right yeah really is
you've been weakened with a lapel you
will get ads for things you talked about
I mean that has been proven hmm so what
is that what is these passive listening
devices they're only picking up key
words it's no big deal it's just key
word it's the frog in the water that's
I'm telling you yeah so I don't know
what's gonna go like I said I'm a little
old folk old fogey about that but I
think we'll resolve it do you think they
should be regulation generally if you
have something good and it gets abused
you regulated that's the whole point of
rape that's we're here alive today
because of regulation because there are
nefarious people who in control of
powerful forces operating on society
would gain at the expense of everyone
else and would not be good for the
progress of civilization
so you regulate okay airlines are
regulated so that you don't die all
right what we have the safest record now
ever for commercial airlines American
carriers the safest ever look at look at
not only how many people have not died
relative to when we grew up we grew up
through at least one or two planes
crashed each year you'd lose between 1
and 300 people every year that was like
the baseline number that number is near
zero now and way more planes are taking
off and landing that in anytime when we
were kids
so it's a double it's a double
Progress point for not only the
Transportation Safety Administration but
engineering technology and everything we
care about we want to fly so you
regulate you make sure these are
inspected this often you don't the
pilots don't fly more than this many
hours you this gets oiled this gets
replaced it's one of the triumphs of
modern engineering aerodynamics
aerospace engineering as a branch of
what we do as civilization is one of the
greatest achievements there ever was
agreed Jamie did you find that stealth
stuff I found there are cars that have
this wouldn't be a car this would be a
laboratory the laboratory find anything
okay oh look at a laboratory stealth
light Oh something try that like cloaks
that people wear that sort of seems like
video yeah but in Harry Potter the the
was the cloak that they wear the
invisibility cloak
that would be this principle yeah if it
existed it with that there's a bunch of
videos of that but it seems like they're
just using After Effects like Adobe or
something like that to death [ __ ] with
the video rather than create an actual
product that's because there was a woman
in an office that had a blanket and she
held up the blanket and you could only
see the whole office you wouldn't see
the blanket at all you'd see what's
behind her she lowered the blanket you
could see her and then from the blanket
down so why isn't that just a green
screen of the yeah that's what it was I
think she was holding up a green blanket
no no no no sorry sorry no no no there's
nothing to do with that okay that's
that's the map of dark matter in the
universe a three-dimensional map I've
tried to give that a shot no we don't
know what it is so don't worry about if
you don't understand yeah but it's too
goddamn confusing for math no it's not
confusing at all it's not it's something
out there that has 85% of the gravity of
the universe and we don't know what the
hell it is
using it's not confusing it's it's if
you don't know what a fuse it is it's
confusing by nature okay III have more
nuanced definition of confusing
confusing is I am confused I don't know
how to think dark matter is I don't even
know what to think I need something in
my head to be confused right dark matter
has there's no we don't know what the
hell do you anticipate a solution to
that or some server sure I want my eyes
it in Hawaii
I hope damn it might have been yeah now
let's go might have been yeah listen
folks it's not the gdt there'll be the
goddamn it's the TMT 30 meter telescope
so yeah solutions to we you don't know
part of the what it is to explore is not
knowing what it is that you will find
and all these telescopes the launched
ones as well as the ground-based ones we
have enough foresight we're mature
enough as a field to know that even
though it's designed to look for certain
things that were part of the program
that you set up for it you want to have
a serendipity mode for it you want to be
able to say let's point it in some
random direction and see what shows up
without that you could miss something in
plain sight if you're only looking for
one thing that you think is there
extrapolated from what you knew before
and the way I think of it you know
there's the old saying as the area of
our knowledge grows so too does the
perimeter of our ignorant mmm so as that
area grows there more places to look
over the fence and stare into the abyss
of ignorance that awaits you so dark
matter is sitting on the other side of
the fence that's the way I've heard
describes the bonfire of our knowledge
grows brighter the area of our ignorant
is illuminated okay
I have to think about that yeah that's
similar to what I said I'm more theater
yeah
if the bonfire is your knowledge that's
lighting the way as it grows bigger you
go see more stuff you've never you've
never noticed before it's the same
principle that's a giant one though man
85 person it's 85 percent of gravity
so yeah it's Andy add that to the dark
energy we don't know that is either dark
matter dark energy comprise 95% of
everything that's driving the universe
so everything we know and love the
chemistry the physics the biology life
planets stars is 5% of the universe now
so many people theologians and folks say
well maybe God is in the other 95% maybe
ok yeah made God's dark matter would
that be crazy well people say that
surprised yeah but I don't know why dark
red would care about whether yeah which
religion you're right yeah all the
religions got their thing wearing yo
don't you know I'm God I'm dark matter
yeah we by the way just in in letters
from an astrophysics physicist which
isn't out yet but again I don't know how
the hell you got the book but it's there
there's an entire chapter where I am
conversing with people who were strongly
religious there's a conversation I have
in there with a Orthodox Jewish person a
Muslim multiple fundamentalist
Christians and we're talking about the
age of the earth and why and why do we
think one way or another and so that's
there's a lot of intimate stuff in there
that I generally don't go public with
but I would did it one-on-one with those
who had written to me about these
challenges they were facing in life and
they wanted to know what a national
physicist had to say about it what's the
youngest version of how old a religious
person thinks to the earth is what's the
how was the 6,000 years see that's a
question yes yet Christian well oh of
all and not all Christians by the way no
no of all religions I don't know the age
College is like a month old
idea I don't know enough about how old
all the religions think the universe is
the youngest you're gonna get the
youngest University owner to get from a
devout Christian in 6,000 years the
oldest is around 10,000 and but it's far
and away from billions Mormons are a
unique one because they think you get
your own planet when you die
yeah and what's what's funny horn on
that what I want my own planet nobody
told me that it's odd how one religious
group would would comment on how
preposterous another religious groups
comments are I love that you know I was
once I don't if you know this I was once
quoted after I think the the Scientology
documentary came out on HBO and
everybody was talking about at least I
think that was it and there was a lot of
chat about it for a couple of weeks and
one of the news outlets I forgot who
called me up and said do I think
Scientology should be a religion
classified as a religion as an authentic
religion and you can ask well why they
calling me Wow
well because in Scientology they're
aliens and if there's space beings that
have us to give up this information oh
sorry I died so that's how I got brought
into this conversation ah because of the
sectors of Scientology that involves
space beings okay all right so my answer
was we live in a country that protects
the free expression of faith based
systems provided they don't subtract
from the rights of others so I will not
sit here and judge whether they tans
from space exhumed souls from volcanoes
at least a third of what I just said is
accurate it's from from the Scientology
or whether a man born of a woman is this
son of God who died and rose from the
dead I'm not going to compare those and
judge whether one of them is more
authentic than another when they're both
founded on belief systems and so in this
country belief systems are protected and
we've all bought into that and so you
know what the headline was Tyson defense
that was the clickbait of my comments
get clicks you got a distort there there
are some rational people who in the
comment thread said that's not what he
said of course yeah but isn't it more
interesting when they do do that and
then inside the actual article itself
they give your full quote so people can
see the deception the real confusing
thing is when they take a chunk of your
quote so you don't I just go to jail for
that by the what so that's interesting
so for me I I'm an observer of that not
a complainer about it so is that how
they're doing it okay so maybe I can
shake this phrase differently to
minimize the chance of that happening in
the future
minimize the chance of you being lied
about correct so for me that is a
landscape there's some landmines here
there are some trap doors here there is
something and so for me one who
communicates on that landscape that's
just information for me to navigate it
slightly more nimbly in the front yeah
got it
interesting gravity this is one thing
that will still hook to hook up on
gravity yes I'm always hooked up on
gravity because as you should be well
since we've talked last I've been
reading a lot about it and one of the
things that confuses me the most is that
we don't really understand what gravity
is we know its effects we can measure
them we know how to measure them we know
what that mass is involved well we don't
really know what gravity is there's a
similar question in the book but they
got a little more philosophical than you
just did but they both leaned
philosophical it's science can describe
how gravity works but can they describe
why
can we so this is the how why yeah
duality here and allow me to just answer
it from a howwhy point of view and then
we can apply it to gravity okay after I
say that in science if we can describe
how something works and predict its
future behavior we claim to understand
it and we move on you can ask deeper
question about why is there gravity what
is the meaning what is the purpose and
go ahead but I'm good with what I've
done and I can land a spacecraft on Mars
inside of a crater in a hole in one
using my understanding of gravity so I'm
pretty good with it okay so I'm not
distracted by the more philosophical
side of that why does it work okay
Einstein so Newton was deeply puzzled by
how you can have something called in
which he coined the phrase action at a
distance okay he wrote down the equation
that worked
he walked any question goes around the
earth earth goes on the Sun the moons of
Jupiter go around Jupiter he accurately
described that with his equations of
gravity okay he said one day I think
we're gonna find some way that they're
connecting to each other but I don't
know what that is right now but I know
my equations work he called it spooky it
was spooky to him that's his word spooky
action at a distance
all right fast forward three hundred
years three hundred no fast forward two
hundred and fifty two hundred thirty
years get to Albert Einstein gravity is
the curvature of space and time and
you're moving on the curvature of that
fabric that's gravity oh my gosh is it
even a force then is it even so there's
no need to think of it as an action at a
distance and in a phrase first uttered
by I think was John Archibald wheeler or
a student of Einstein and he I learned
relativity from John Archibald wheeler
fact that's where I met my wife in
relativity class
at school its space so matter tells
space how to curve space tells matter
how to move it moves on the curvature of
space
you don't need an action at a distance
there is no action it can't do anything
else but do that it's like you have a
funnel and you take a ball and you roll
it on the funnel the ball can only do
what that funnel tells it to do and
it'll Cirque if you give it a sideways
motion it'll start spinning around
there's no magic hand coming in there it
is following the curvature of its
space-time continuum this construct that
you provided for it so now I can
describe what gravity is doing I even
have a mechanism for it are you gonna
still ask me why is there gravity is
that answered not fulfilling enough to
you even in the Y Department because
well why would a particle curved space
you can just keep doing that that's fine
but is there a point really where you'll
be satisfied with the answer oh that
answers my why I can say well why did
this half liter of water drop off the
edge here
well it's no longer the forces are
imbalanced and it's a no but why did it
fall well there's nothing holding you
know why did there's a point where it's
not especially productive to continue to
think about the world that way because
what I'm claiming is answers to the how
when you understand the how enough our
tantamount to having answered the why
question that's all that's what I'm
telling them out in terms of your
ability to measure it and accurately use
it correct so we can say okay but isn't
it you've got a ball yes we can say well
why did you go bald well okay the hair
follicles at a when you start in your
late 20s and early
go bald when you start losing your hair
probably late twenties early thirties
yeah yeah that's that's common if you
have your hair when you're thirty you'll
probably have it for the rest of your
life that's the how that goes you start
losing it up right going up to your
thirty so you can say well the hair
follicle begins does not producing the
keratin or whatever we get the
explanation then you say well why does
the hair follicle stop doing that then
you say oh well because the DNA has a
pre coded about the hair kind of thing
well why does the DNA have the hair well
because so whereas we know far more
about how and why people go bald than we
do about what gravity really is correct
I'm telling you gravity really is the
curvature of space and time that gets us
the Big Bang and everything we've ever
known and based in time but it's also
based on mass right it's based on the
amount of any concentration of matter
and energy and or energy will curve the
fabric of space and time and the more
the movement of matter on that fabric of
space and time we call gravity and I'm
good with that
okay but you seem a little oddly
defensive about something that's
scientific no I have to say I'm good
with this but you you are cuz you kind
of defending it no you can say well if Y
does matter you need to know why uh-huh
why they say no I'm saying why does
matter and energy curve the fabric of
space and time you can ask that okay why
and I don't have an answer if I can say
well that's all I'm asking
well no what about to what I'm telling
you is okay you don't need to watch you
to the point all right we had to walk to
that point where you're why got
unanswered I understand that but but
before we got to that point
I answered otherwise that I'm not
disputing that good good so what I'm
telling you is that I can answer your
why question most of the time but then
you'll come back to a point where
there's a point where there's the Y
doesn't have the answer so you say why
did if falling say there's a force of
gravity operating on it why did it fall
that way because of the curvature of
space and time I'm answering your wise
then why does matter an energy curve
space and time okay that's a frontier
we're still working on that but that's
all I'm asking that's good that's one
you are a man of science so you are a
person that should probably embrace wise
accept the many people who ask why
questions they really want to no purpose
I'm not asking purpose good well then
that distinguishes you from many other
people who ask why questions oh okay why
did you bang the table I was angry
there's a purpose behind it okay so so
yeah if your Y is just a curiosity of
what's going on that's one thing if you
are inquiring about purpose then its
theological okay because when a
theological then religions give purpose
to lot merely I'm not doing that right
but uh I just think it's amazing that
something that's such a massive part of
life on this planet that we stayed glued
to the ground because of gravity can you
pull up my Instagram account that I only
posts you have an Instagram account now
I had a fake one for a while yeah I took
it over mine actually I know that guy I
took it over he gave it to you oh dude
the guy who had it yeah no no no no
actually I sorry
yes Instagram said I but people think
this is a real account and it's not can
I have it back and if it's an account
that's an impostor and followers don't
know it it's illegal right so so there's
there's one that says fan of neil tyson
yeah and that's a different one okay so
I only post arthouse photos okay that
I've taken most of which I've taken so
just scroll down and look for Muscle
Beach there it is click on that okay so
here's my cat go to my caption go
fullscreen on that remember my cab okay
for most of our life on earth we either
resist or succumb to the force of
gravity at Muscle Beach gravity loses
every time room I was proud of the
caption you know you call me out on that
caption that's nonsense
gravity never loses gravity doesn't even
have like little tiny losses there's a
war for those just listening to this so
I was at I was in Venice California and
the Sun was setting behind some guy who
was doing who was doing hand pressed
hand presses suspended up on this chin
up bar right and it was really so it was
cool he was silhouetted there's a palm
tree there's the beach he's there
gravity's gonna beat that [ __ ]
let me tell you eventually but while he
is it while he's there he's conquering
gravity are you getting too old you
haven't come to gravity lately no I work
out all the time I'm not buying it yeah
concrete [ __ ] he's pulling rank now so I
work out and you don't cuz I see your
middle-aged man belly well what I've
talked to other astrophysicists and
science what way let me yet are these
conversations supposed to have a like a
theme or a purpose or is it just you sit
in just whatever comes your head you
send my where are you and me yeah well
clearly this episode is about you can't
say that I don't ever do you don't do
that okay fine that's just episode
number two my success no hablo
commitment ever have a thread think
about all the different people of course
of course it's like impossible of
calling fighters and scientists and the
scholars and crackpots bunch of
different people coming through here man
I can't have any agenda all right I mean
that's probably the only reason why this
thing is successful as it is yeah but
that's a weird one for people that this
one thing that is so powerful what what
is Oh gravity that's a weird one for
people yeah I mean it seems like you're
frustrated by all the various questions
no like no you seem a little little
defensive there because I follow that I
thought you were taking your why to
ultimately mean purpose if it's just why
I'm claiming that many responses to how
are also responses to a why mm-hmm that
that's that's the point I'm making and I
don't like splitting definitions will
ultimately understand gravity I think we
do that's why we can land things
Mars I think we do which is why your
cell phone gets time from GPS satellites
that is pre corrected for Einstein's
general theory of relativity because
they're in a different gravitational
field than you in orbit than you are on
Earth's surface we got this we got Stein
his triumphing we're running short on
time here so I set you something that I
wanted to ask you what's that you I did
I did it's about a black hole that
landed in a mysterious place in our
understandings yes yeah yeah so let me
let me just give that I'll give the the
the sort of Reader's Digest version of
this okay okay
there are black holes that are there
black holes that are formed at the
consequence of the death of stars okay
okay and we think we understand the
formation of stars well enough to say
well star is born with this much mass
and it'll lose certain amount of mass
over its life all stars lose mass
because there's so much pressure and so
much energy coming out it carries
particles with it so they they lose mass
the Sun is losing mass as we speak it's
called the solar wind
so everybody loses mass out there the
question is at what rate are you losing
mass is it a lot compared to your total
mass is it small so very high mass stars
are not especially stable objects they
remain stars for a hundred thousand at
most a million years and they'll explode
and become a supernova if you're more
massive than that they will not explode
because the gravity is so strong that it
cannot explode against the strength of
the gravity and it collapses into a
black hole so we expect black holes to
have slightly less mass somewhat less
mass then the most massive stars that we
know how to make so if you have a
hundred times the mass of the Sun star
it'll lose half of its mass over its
life and you have a a black hole that 30
times the mass of the Sun or 50 times
the mass isn't fine put a pin in that
in the Centers of galaxies there are
supermassive black holes hundreds of
thousands millions times the mass of the
Sun and we call their supermassive and
their black holes we call them
supermassive black holes because that's
how we roll as astrophysicists
all right well could you have black
holes somewhere in the middle of these
two extremes we do not know a phenomenon
that will give you a black hole that's
in beat that will birth a black hole
that's in between these two these two
categories you can make a black hole
that eats its way there fine but we
don't know how to make one and we think
we colleagues who have done this think
they've discovered a black hole that is
sitting in this sort of netherworld
where there's no evidence that it ate to
become that massive and we don't know
how to explain it by the formation and
death of stars and is nowhere near the
supermassive black hole in the center of
the galaxy so it is the frontier of
research at this moment so it's just a
newly discovered type of black hole it's
in a MASH regime that this physically
impossible you know headlines we're
eating the headline now black hole shock
they show me the the where disappears
express is this a British I think
they're British anyhow it's a news
digest for science so black hole shock
theories swirl around the discovery of a
physically impossible black hole so
scientists don't use the word impossible
unless it's violating a known law of
physics so I bet that was a title and I
don't have a product I don't mind a
little bit of sensationalism there you
can say it is a black hole that comes
from and if it comes from an object it
is an object we know nothing about and
have yet to discover well we're not
going to say it's an impossible on Jeff
mm-hmm every time we point a telescope
to the universe we find something that
we never predicted or understood and it
adds to the knowledge base already have
whenever they do discover things and
then
that becomes what we know and understand
like the supermassive black holes at the
center of every galaxy that was a fairly
recent discovery in terms it was a sized
because we saw the Centers of galaxies
behaving really weirdly things stars
were moving faster than they should have
given how much gravity was tugging on
them and we said dude something's got to
be there and it's got to be really small
because we're tracking star is really
close to the middle well if it was made
of ordinary matter how big would have to
have to be really really big so this has
to be really really small in order for
this to happen the only thing we know
that could fill that small volume and
have that much gravity is a black hole
so it's suspected for a long time it was
confirmed that as a common thing by the
Hubble telescope and first photographed
by this recent result in the galaxy m87
Messier 87 is what it's that's the name
of the galaxy and you can determine how
big the black hole is based on the size
of the galaxy we can determine the mass
of the black hole by how fast stars are
moving at the distance they are from it
so in other words so so where Earth
orbiting the Sun and we have a certain
speed we're going about forgot how does
it but 18 miles per second I think
that's the number 30 kilometers a second
that's our speed around that's a speed
around the Sun that's pretty fast okay
if the Sun had more mass instantly that
speed is not enough to maintain our
orbit and we'll start spiraling in
towards it if the Sun had less mass that
speed is too high to be in this orbit
it'll take it to up sorry it's too fast
to maintain this horbet it'll climb us
out to a higher orbit slow us down and
we'll be in a higher orbit with a slower
speed so in other words for any object
at any distance there's only one speed
you can maintain and have a stable orbit
around it so when we see stars orbiting
something in the center of the galaxy it
is a straight forward Astro 1:02
equation to calculate how much mass the
thing is orbiting and you get the mass
and you can't see it it's
it's a black hole and that ladies and
gentlemen is the end of the podcast ha
ha ha this block will be available when
Sir comes out in in October first week
of October I'm very proud of this book
it's my most heartfelt thing that I've
ever done well when it comes out I will
take a photograph and put it up on the
Instagram and the Twitter yeah and it's
it's a it also has letters from people
in prison a person who had just learned
that they were had terminal cancer I
mean there's a lot of people reaching
out responding to letters yes it's me
responding and they're letters I can't
fit all of their letters some are very
long tones but most of their letters and
then all of my correspondence is in
there so it's it's my most heartfelt
contribution to this universe and
Startalk is still upon we're still going
still going Startalk would pump it up in
50 episodes and a television show yes so
we can see if we're gonna have a new
season we don't know yet that's to be
announced but we're going to it's always
a podcast and I we got a YouTube channel
Startalk YouTube channel and we're
thinking of branching out into other
kinds of educational product that's
still fun and comedic and the like and I
love your support for this because
you're you're also a comedian so you
know the value and I love comedians that
have their fundamental part of how we
deliver science to the public on
Startalk so thanks for for that plug my
applies are my friend dude thank you
always good bye everybody
[Applause]
[Music]